[Applaudissements]
un motard est actuellement chez un de
nos chroniqueurs on a réussi à se
procurer les clés de l'un d'entre vous
et mokhtar s'est introduit chez lui
mokhtar est ce que vous pouvez montrer
un premier objet pour voir si la
personne comprend que c'est chez lui
tout de suite ou pas ce que vous avez un
premier objet allez-y mokhtar mokhtar
est ce que vous avez un truc
ah ouais est ce que quelqu'un
reconnaisse a quand même quelques cas
reconnaît ça c'est pas chez vous déjà
fait sa carrière à la lime mais comment
tu veux qu'on reconnaît comme ça c'est
quelqu'un qui cuisinent pas le reconnaît
pas sa casserole à chaud là bas 2e objet
et moctar bah c'est moi mokhtar sera
deuxième objet c'est quoi ça
c'est un parapluie et papa du rouge qui
à part à pirou j'avoue c'est pas chez
moi s'est passé vous s'est passé vous
non qu'ils commencent à dire que c'est
chez lui tout en douceur
en 1728 rouge n'a pas plus de golf vous
avez pas un motard est ce qu'on peut
aller voir chez pas placer bout devant
la télé par exemple passé vous devant la
télé placez vous devant la télé qui à ce
chien qui associa et oui c'est
jean-michel
genlis honneur
oujda et en direct que c'est jean-michel
vert alors le jeu est très simple
jean michel vous avez une relation très
particulière avec thierry mot magique
avec son chien j'ai parfois aussi avec 0
vous avez une relation très particulière
je vais donc posé des questions à
thierry moreau et à chaque fois
si thierry mauron répond mme al mokhtar
fera ce qu'il a à faire
marie s'échauffent en plus j'étais eux
je suis pas bien ah mais moi je suis
encore celle des broutards mokhtar
calmez-vous ces bons recouler reculer
vous tous moins de la télé c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon on va pas reculer
vous de la télé tu as l'élan qui fit
souvent à la télé si bota bota
saisissez-vous d'une scie et mettez vous
devant la table mais non on va alors
égale on rigole bon allez attention
voici la question une question pour
thierry moreau la vache et rim os
voici la première question qu'on va vous
poser mon chien oui ou de quelques
couleurs de quelle couleur est la
nouvelle voiture de jean michel mer
noire c'est une bonne réponse allait
bien noir là bas
[Applaudissements]
monk a reculé de la télé remettez votre
appart ou les latéraux tulle et de la
télé mokhtar reculé de la télé on va
poser une deuxième question mokhtar
mettez vous sur la table de jean michel
meriem petite table à voile à cette
petite table pour vous prenez une s'il
prenait ici c'est la table sur laquelle
jean michel meyer travail
voilà vous avez une scie voilà très bien
vous avez une six moteurs ou pas a dit
là dessus il ya aussi votre attention
non non non non attention attention hein
voilà la question est facile thierry
moreau comment s'appelle le modèle de
cette table des propositions burse tas
ou grichka furst à mokhtar mokhtar poser
c'est si oui c'est poser c'est si cette
réponse à perdre la vie
[Applaudissements]
voici voici la question motards mettez
vous dans le placard mettez-vous de vol
placard mokhtar parce que je vais poser
une nouvelle question à thierry moreau
allez-vous mettre devant le placard
mokhtar attention thierry moreau
combien de caleçons possède jean michel
maire combien de caleçons poserait de
jean michel mr 0 ce qui portent pas de
dessous motard est ce qu'on peut
vérifier mon maire de caleçons possède
jean michel mr mokhtar mokhtar on paie
le placard à les y voilà
allez-y voila voila lesquels il en ad
calcio
oui on a déjà parlé à beaucoup d'égards
[Applaudissements]
la trouver bahia n'a plus que c est la
plus et la passion et elle a beaucoup
mokhtar mettez pas votre malade dans
vous allez attraper des maladies ce
nom-là ses bras les gibbons allégis
mokhtar enlever tout lesquelles son
regard des skis à les y aller niveau car
mon chien attaque et bien aller à ces
mort à la deux
oui mais qu'elle allait vite beau aller
vite potard son propre oui oui c'est
beau oui allez c'est bon mais qu'on
avait au sabre à cannes devant avocat
[Applaudissements]
ah bonjour mon corps mon cas à retourner
dans le salon motards aux cellules
oui je suis là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et ça n'est pas un truc à je n'allais
pas un truc à ce motard tourner dans le
salon mokhtar aux tournées dans une
salle au regard d un superbe tableau
regarder ce tableau l'ail est bon il est
très très beau eux
mokhtar je vais poser une question
regarder ce tableau au regard des tirs
est mort et regarder le tableau
attention regardez bien c'est un très
beau tableau mokhtari
si thierry moreau répond mal prenez vous
avez un rouleau à peinture mais non
bravo car il ya quelqu'un qui comprend
aller le chercher là où va surtout qu'il
faut très bien vous allez la toiture
ouais il a tous ces beaux alors voici la
question si raymond vous avez vu le
tableau
alors attention regardez regardez chez
vous regardez chez vous regardez ce
tableau pendant 5 secondes s'il vous
plaît on regarde ce tableau pendant 5
secondes
le tableau s'il vous plaît merci le
cadreur le tableau le cadre c'est beau
combat y at-il de queue de cerise un an
sur cette oeuvre
oui ce sommet y at il deux queues de
cerises sur cette oeuvre non là c'est
bon allez alesi on augmente plus le
tableau on ne montre plus le tableau
s'il vous plaît mais la regarde en forêt
dense by them il y en a 15 case mokhtar
al et gimont fait un petit peu la
peinture c'est jean-michel rpm après la
peinture métal non non non mais sérieux
a pas sur le tableau pas sur le tableau
non mais les foules sera pas sur le
tableau
non
jamais des façons les tableaux non même
saluer motards samaras et moi c'est moi
ça va c'est beau c'est bon c'est vrai au
bota bota c'est bon c'est bon motard on
va retourner dans la chambre on va
retourner dans la chambre s'est pas
laissé beaucoup plus beau comme ça que
les jours c'est vrai alors atteinte aux
motards alesi retour est retournée dans
la chambre
attention tu vas retourner la chambre et
j'ai posé une question thierry quelles
sont les dimensions exactes du 10 de
jean-michel quelles sont les dimensions
exactes du lit de jean michel aulas en a
les dimensions et de son financement par
deux commères 180 marche de l'ue 180 par
deux motards vous avez toujours un mètre
sur vous il a dix ans 80 par deux genoux
pouvait mesurer le lead jean-michel
moctar sow s'en [ __ ] merci oui merci
mokhtar allez dire merci moqtada sadr
jeudi le sujet d'ouverture est alors
trop bien ah oui quand même
moi je mesure oui combien ça va motards
195 bon bah c'est bon c'est déjà perdu
184 et boba matin c'est déjà perdu
mokhtar de ballons c'est moi ça dort
balance et moi ce alors balancé mois sa
part la snet alesi motards ça va ça va
arrêter ben c'est pas s'être vraiment
des u20 motards n'ont jamais vos cartes
eastwood
il ne faut jamais je suis sage ceci
montre malades mal otages trois chronos
sa maladie a fait tout ce qu'on lui
nicolas saada me
[Applaudissements]
vos stars il me tarde et voilà l'ultime
question ultime question thierry moreau
ce sera la dernière combien de fip ton
faire entrer dans la chambre de jean
michel maire combien
à votre avis 15a les 15 15 mon cas je
crois qu'on a on a on a tapé à la porte
autant je crois qu'on a sonné volta on
tape à la porte
web va nous dire les matches
me chabert
[Applaudissements]
non
je
à la 36 jeunes gens meurent
moi dans les yeux
sans glisser du seul bon michel paris
s'est abîmé
vénus noire dans l'otan
jean bouchaud
[Applaudissements]
jean michel jean michel et sa salle au
saas et logiciels
elle reste chez jean-michel envers si
les filles merci les chiens et
jean-michel juste un petit truc
sachez que le tableau vous y tenez bah
oui quand même
on vous avait fait c'était c'était leur
production donc oui possible
je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est pas
votre vraie table ou non je vous promets
que c'est mal ah bah oui bien sûr
d'aller pas faire ça sur votre tableau
non je vous promets que c'est vrai on a
le vrai tableau ne vous inquiétez pas on
a pris une photo où la roche est un jeu
doute ballon et non mais je vous promets
je dis que c'est une reproduction de
tableaux
en fait c'est une photo voilà d'accord
an plus tôt c'est bien chez vous sinon
bah oui ça c'est chez moi mais je tiens
à préciser que les caleçons c'est pas
les miens étaient dégueulasses alors
scellé vous je vous jure que c'est vrai
et le et le et le truc qu'il a trouvé la
culotte qui est le fruit je vous jure
que c'est vrai qu'on la paralysie
peut-être jean-michel vers bordeaux
jean-michel est d'aimer clés ont
remercié votre pote alex vraiment être
un amoureux alex
[Musique]